Suppose we want to use regular expressions
to recognize phone numbers with or without hyphens.
This is super common in electronic commerce.
Here I have 2 positive examples from the American phone system,
123-4567 and 1234567.
But we want our business to be international,
so we also want to accept numbers in other formats,
like these French telephone numbers, which have 5 groups of 2
if they're separated by hyphens or just 10 digits otherwise.
And in general, we want to allow any number of groups of any non-empty size
separated by 1 hyphen where each group is 0 through 9+.
And my hint is you should remember to accept a super small phone number
like 5--presumably from many years ago when there weren't that many phones--
but do not accept -6 because there is nothing on the left of the hyphen.
This problem is tricky, and you should submit via the interpreter
by defining a variable called regexp that encodes this.